emergency teams worked all through the
night to save people trapped under the
rubble the magnitude 6.2 earthquake
struck just before midnight most were
asleep in their homes the epicenter was
jushan County in China's Northern Gansu
Province neighboring chhai was also
affected dozens of people have been
killed and hundreds
injured so far we have deployed 1,500
firefighters more than a th000 soldiers
and another 1,500 policemen to the
earthquake area for rescue work a series
of powerful Tremors lasted 20 seconds
each and could be felt in the provincial
capital more than 100 kilometers
away social media videos show people
rushing out onto the streets in search
of
safety the government says more than
4,700 homes have been destroyed
telecommunications Power and Water
Supplies have been cut off officials say
subzero temperatures across northern
China are hampering rescue and Recovery
it's currently about -1° C during the
day and drops to -14 at night forcing
emergency teams to work as quickly as
they can authorities are Distributing
tents blankets cooking stoves and food
to survivors the government has
allocated $30 million for disaster
relief warning residents to expect
magnitude 5.0 aftershocks in the coming
days Katrina U aler Beijing